fue el propio Pelé quien decidió
organizar su funeral y el Astro del
fútbol quería que estuviera abierto al
público aquí sobre el césped del estadio
del Santo es un equipo que le entronizó
lo entronizó como el rey del fútbol
público en general y personalidades
llegaron hasta este lugar para
despedirse y se esperaba especialmente a
un político el nuevo presidente
brasileño Luis Ignacio lulada Silva que
llegó alrededor de las nueve de la
mañana hora local con su esposa yangya y
un importante dispositivo de seguridad
durante su visita se ofreció un acto
religioso en memoria de Pelé en medio de
su enfermedad que transitó durante la
crisis del covid firmó una camisa el
Santos con el número diez para Jair
bolsonaro lo que generó en la época
polémica a pesar de que nunca mostró su
apoyo a la hora presidente la visita de
Lula es vista como un momento de unión
entre los brasileños y su nuevo
mandatario en torno a un tema que los
une el fútbol después de meses de
campaña presidencial y división política
luego de una procesión que conduce el
cuerpo de Pelé hacia el cementerio
vertical más alto del mundo los restos
descansaran en su última morada en vida
el futbolista eligió este lugar al
considerarlo un cementerio no deprimente
como se lo dijo en intimidad a su
familia un cementerio que sin duda se
convertirá desde mañana en un lugar de
peregrinaje para los aficionados al
fútbol de todo el mundo